que peut-il coraux et guillaume
depardieu bonsoir je suis ravi de vous
accueillir j'ai beaucoup aimé le film
afin de vous poser quelques questions
c'est la première fois que vous voyez
ces extraits oui utile oui ça vous
touche beaucoup
mais j'aime beaucoup le film et vous
guillaume il aime aussi
ouais je crois alors ce film joue un peu
je dirais la vie contre la mort la
passion contre l'absurdité de la guerre
j'ai envie de dire que vos deux héros
vos deux rôles incarne la force la
vitalité la violence est ce que c'est un
peu une forme de résistance l'amour oui
mais c'est une forme de résistance et il
faut résister aujourd'hui encore
guillaume surtout va falloir m'aider un
peu
alors vous vous jouez un rôle celui
d'une institutrice pris un peu dans les
vertiges de la guerre j'ai envie de dire
que c'est une femme extrêmement moderne
dynamique presque contemporaine
alors qu'elle est du début du siècle
vous êtes une femme libre comme ça ni
certainement mais je vais j'essaie
d'aller jusqu'au bout de mes désirs
comme marthe j'essaie d'être courageuse
et voilà malgré sincère qu'est ce qui
vous a plu dans ce rôle max est une
femme courageuse et ce que je me dire
forte libre et qui va jusqu'au bout de
son sentiment alors c'est extraordinaire
parce que quand on vous voit quand on
vous voit jouer on sait vraiment ce que
ça veut dire aimer perdu mon follement
amoureuse absolue s'il faut pas répondre
à cette question là oui j'espère vous
former ce couple romantique vous dire où
vous jouez le rôle de ciment j'irai un
garçon qui n'a pas peur de dire ses
sentiments qui n'a pas peur d'aimer mais
si c'est ça qui le rend peut-être
touchant tous les hommes ont posé nues
hyper de l'idée encore plus en quoi ils
vous ressemblent ce personnage
ben justement dans cette peur
je trouve que c'est assez exalté dans
cette oeuvre là c'est à dire exalté
c'est un sentiment qui enfin cet amour
là je trouve qu'il est a su démontrer
vous avez du bonheur à jouer cet amour
fou cet amour que vous donnez que vous
prenez oui pour quelles raisons vous
allez accepter de faire ce film culte il
se tourne vers vous oui bon je pense
qu'il a accepté pour le scénario parce
que c'est un second temps des paroles et
que là j'ai envie de jouer sans les
scénarios étaient est sublime
on a réussi tous les deux je crois que
c'était une très belle histoire et on
avait envie de vivre d'abord de défendre
ces personnages là vous avez été
immédiatement séduite lorsque vous avez
lu scénario moi je vous aurais quand
j'ai lu le scénario j'ai pleuré parce
que j'espérais vivre une histoire comme
ça j'espère bien y sort que bien alors
il ya l'histoire d'amour il ya aussi
filmé remarquablement la boule la
boucherie des tranchées la saleté de
cette guerre avec des hommes jeunes très
jeunes
vous vous souvenez de la première tirade
du film nous et vous guillaume vous
souvenez comment comment ce film ouais
vous pourriez dire ce que ce qui se
passe
il ya un long plan travelling qui est
très fort sur les tranchées [ __ ] j'ai
jamais besoin donc c'est le premier mot
du chum c'est un premier jeune homme qui
va rester a fait ce film résume ce que
vous venez de faire admirablement
dois-je le dire béatrice c'est-à-dire
présenter un monde atroce au quotidien
avec dextérité
mais cette nuit gamin avait 18 ans et à
l'époque c'était à peu près ça
finalement c'était des gamins qu'on
envoyait à la mort la mort et c'est vrai
qu'on a toujours un peu en idées les
poilus de la guerre de 14
on n'imagine pas que déjà une
expérimentée des jeunes soldats qui sont
partis ça vous a touché alors gérard
jugnot bon tout à fait remarquable
séduisant dans ce rôle on l'a vu dans
les extraits je vais vous poser une
question que je trouve pas personnel
puisque vous l'avez déclaré vous avez
dit que vous allez arrêter le cinéma je
vais savoir si c'était une décision
irrévocable pour l'instant si c'était le
besoin d'un autre pari si le cinéma vous
avez blessés non moi j'aime bien dire ce
que je fais faire ce que je dis donc un
patio d'un comédien ou pas très
intéressant vous êtes déjà lassé peu
comédiens eux et vous allez trouver
d'autres chemins par exemple surprise s
car un peu d'harmonie dans les chemins
que vous allez prendre j'espère qu'elle
sera votre prochain film petits des gros
il y en a deux il ya karim dridi hors
jeu et puis guillaume clou le poulpe
avec jean pierre darroussin
voilà je remercie tous les deux d'avoir
répondu à nos questions